we're joined now by author and columnist
mark Stein who has been watching from
the very first gavel hammer great to see
you mark Stein so you you now are one of
I would say America's great experts on
this impeachment trial having greedily
consumed every moment of it what's your
assessment so far well it's a complete
stinker from beginning to end I think
you saw the problem with it with
Dershowitz of the view a constitutional
lawyer shouldn't really be having to put
himself in that situation and the
problem here is loyally arguments in
fact there's no point making loyally
arguments this is a completely political
process people say that you know the
trouble with loyally arguments is that
if it's political the president can't be
doing this well you know even if you
accept everything that John Bolton says
is true that's all the complete that's
all a complete waste of time
I think he should actually have defended
himself my problem with this bore of an
impeachment trial the ratings are so low
Adam Schiff might as well have kept it
in that skiff on sub-basement level
three there's nobody watching this and
in fact it's not enough of a circus and
Trump should have defended himself and
shove this thing down Adam Schiff throat
directly the whole process is stupid the
Chief Justice reading out these
handwritten cards by Patrick Leigh which
in fact is written for him by some
no-name staffer in his office and then
there you have the Chief Justice like
some game show hostess what's the next
question John the whole thing is
ridiculous
Trump should've represented himself and
turned it into a real circus so sorry
that's such an interesting point I mean
I as I've watched us I keep thinking I
wonder if the Republicans are being too
literal and that's the reason we went
full Dada in the open tonight because
it's like it's hard to take it seriously
and I wonder if it's a mistake to take
it seriously it's utterly so the charges
don't even make sense they're guilty of
the crimes they'd choose that could use
the president of committing like the
whole thing is so nutso maybe it's
better just to like say that out loud
well I would have said
there's their as they say in English
courts I shift should have made his case
and the Democrats made their case and
then the defense should just have stood
up and said as they say in English
courts no case to answer and left it at
that and the only thing I would add is
that the only real crime here to go back
to what you were saying about Ukraine
Ukraine is our greatest ever ally
Ukraine was there when we stormed the
beaches of Normandy Ukrainian volunteers
were at Fort Sumter they've been with us
throughout the history of the Republic
the only crime in this thing was hunted
by his committee by hunter Biden who
stole the wealth of Ukraine from the
people of Ukraine hunter Biden's racket
isn't actually a victimless crime and
the victim was Ukraine that is such a
great point if you really believe the
Ukraine was our essential Ally important
enough to send your son to go die there
which is the case Adam Schiff has made
you would be a little bit upset that
hunter Biden was defrauding Ukraine yeah
absolutely I mean that's the that's the
thing they want to build a Ukraine safe
enough for the sons of lifetime to look
this whole thing is a joke there's not a
real this idea I don't like the lawyers
for the president
appearing to resist they should say John
Bolton bring him on
that's heaven in the witness stand for
two weeks this thing is going so great
for you let's have him here then ask him
all the questions you want we have
nothing to fear this thing's tanking for
you let's extend it to November 3rd 4th
5th and see how it works out for you
losers I'd literally couldn't agree more
that's that's the best case against
impeachment I've heard so far not
surprised mark Stein great to see you
tonight thank you for that thanks a lot
Tucker